hello everybody and welcome back to the
state of the web my guest is Andrew
Betts he's a technical product manager
and developer advocate at fastly and
today we're talking about a bit of web
metadata and is becoming ever more
important to web performance and
security HTTP headers let's get started
[Music]
Andrew thank you for being here
Thanks well Mimi so in addition to your
work at fastly you've also been working
at the w3c technical architecture group
or tag for a couple of years how has
this experience shaped your interest in
headers so I was on the tape for a
couple of years until January this year
and the purpose of the tag really is
it's a review body so working groups
that are either at w3c or other
standards bodies will come up with some
new feature that they want to add to the
web platform and they will take that
spec to the tag for feedback the tag is
has a broad membership it's just people
who have a lot of experience in a
variety of different ways related to the
web so we were in a good position to
give people feedback on a spec proposal
and I found that a lot of the proposals
that were coming to us for review were
not just things like new elements or new
JavaScript API is but there were
actually new HTTP headers and that was
interesting to me because it felt like
this wasn't an area that we were seeing
a lot of innovation and actually there
is a lot of standards work going on so
that was particularly interesting also I
work for fastly and you know we are at
we're an edge network with process a lot
of traffic that goes through the edge of
the internet and we let developers
manipulate that traffic in in various
ways and one of the most popular things
that people like to do is to add and
remove HTTP headers talk to my security
and performance and that kind of thing
so there's a professional interest there
as well I guess the thing that really
sparked my sort of prompted me to do
this research was that I was having a
conversation with Steve Souders he used
to work for Google and before that at
Yahoo and he's written various books on
web performance and he said to me that
he's been using the same technique for
about a decade to clear an object out of
the
browser cache so you know you serve a
JavaScript or a CSS or something at with
a very long cache time and you suddenly
want to clear it from your end users
browser cache how do you do that and he
has this hacky technique for doing it
and he said to me you know Andrea there
must be a better way of doing this now I
haven't done any research into this for
several years and I said we'll have you
heard of clear sight data which is a new
HTTP header and you send this on any
response and it clears your entire
origins cache and he said well no I
haven't heard of that so I thought
that's interesting so Steve salicin
hasn't heard of this then maybe we need
to do a better job of communicating some
of these new headers so I think most
people's familiarity with the cutting
edge of HTTP is probably HTTP - is this
an incremental improvement over HTTP 1-1
or is there like something brand-new in
here that is totally like revolutionary
so I guess it's it's both really so you
know in some ways Age 2 is is just
solving problems better than that we've
we've progressively been solving better
and better in h-11 so when HTTP was
first invented you needed a separate TCP
connection for every request and
response and today that would that would
just not work right you know there's
hundreds of resources on every web page
it would be super slow to have to open a
new connection every single time then in
h-11 we got keep alive so we were able
to reuse the same connection for
multiple resources but they still had to
be sequential so the solution to that
was browsers started opening multiple
TCP connections to the same origin and
parallelizing you know up to four maybe
six connections and that prompted
developers to start using techniques
like domain sharding where you would you
know allocate more than one external
address to essentially the same server
so that you could pretend with multiple
servers and then get your get eight
connections done instead of four and in
h2 we finally do away with that and we
introduced multiplexed requests and
responses on one connection so it no
longer matters how many things you're
requesting from the same origin we can
interleave those packets in any order
so domain sharding would now be an
anti-pattern yeah essentially there
should be no reason for anyone to use
the main shining with h2 at the same
time there are things that are being
introduced in h2 that are not
incremental improvements they're just
completely new concepts like header
compression so until now we've been able
to compress the body content of a web
page using gzip for example but that's
compression is advertised in the heads
so the headers can't be compressed and
that's a shame because actually the
headers are critical content you know
they are they come up in front of the
content that we need to render the page
so it's important that we get the
headers down as quickly as we can and
the headers would be also been getting
bigger at the same time so h2 introduces
had a compression it also allows for a
dictionary to be shared between requests
so on a subsequent request if your
headers are largely the same as the
previous one then they will disappear in
compression that I think is one of the
great improvements in h2 as well you've
also been doing the rounds at
conferences recently you have a
presentation titled headers for hackers
didn't really do analysis into the usage
of headers on the web can you describe
your methodology and how you did the
analysis yeah so after I was done with
this research that I did with Steve on
clearing cache in the browser
I was curious to find out you know the
headers likely a site data and other
things what is their relative popularity
you know like some of these best
practices are probably being adopted
quite well and some of them may be not
showing any adoption at all and so you
know the first step to figuring out why
is to actually find out what the actual
situation is so HTTP archive which
actually Steve started and is sponsored
by Google and fastly is a big database
of the top is it 1 million one point 1.3
1.3 million sites it's there crawled via
webpagetest every couple of weeks and
the entire data set goes into bigquery
and that includes all the response
headers so I can query across all the
headers served on all of those responses
not just on the page response but all
the resources those pages loaded and I
can get a pretty good picture for what
I used on the web today so the web is a
pretty wild place I'd imagine you found
some surprises in there is that right I
did and you know as a as someone who
worked with you know web traffic every
day and also you know two years in in
stannis community looking at new headers
and web standards I thought it was
unlikely that I would see anything in
the top 30 that I didn't recognize and
actually there was one called p3p that I
didn't I didn't know what it was and it
was served by around 10% of the
responses in HTTP archive so I thought
well what is this I looked it up and it
turns out this is a privacy-related
header it's it was designed as a machine
readable statement of privacy policy and
a user agent a browser would surface
this to the user in some way it seems to
me actually when you read the spec like
a really good idea and it's a bit of a
shame that it never actually took whole
but interestingly it was implemented in
some form by Microsoft in Internet
Explorer and it actually was used to
gate access to a small piece of browser
functionality so if developers wanted to
use that functionality they needed to
have a p3p policy but it didn't actually
matter what the policy was because it
wasn't validated by the browser so the
most popular value for this header in
HTTP archive is the phrase this is not a
p3p policy so there's a total waste of
space it is a total waste of space Wow
was there anything else that you found
so I guess PTP use it to be really niche
find one of the more common headers is
is expires everybody knows what that
means and what it does it's 80% of the
responses in the archive include an
expires had a the weird thing is that
the vast majority of them are all set to
the same date and it's a very specific
date it's like 4 p.m. GMT sometime in
December 1994 and what is significant
about that date it's the example in spec
so if you read the HTTP caching spec
there is an example of an expires header
and that is the date that is given so a
couple of things I find interesting
about this the first is that the HTTP
date format includes the day of the week
so if I wanted to
think of an arbitrary date in the past
and it didn't matter what that date was
because I just want to indicate that my
document spired then I could think of a
date in the past but then I would need
to know what day of the week that was in
order to form a valid HTTP date because
I can't do that mentally it's easier
just to copy the example from the spec
the other thing I found interesting was
that if people are serving expires
headers that intentionally contain a
date in the past then a better practice
is to use a more modern header like
cache-control and in fact we quite often
see patterns where people include both a
cache control header and an expires
header and in those situations most
commonly the expires header would be
redundant and will be ignored by the
browser so they're really actually is no
point in setting that header at all
I see you've also done research into X
frame options what did you find there
yeah so vex frame options is an
interesting one because that was one
that I was using myself and I found that
it's a very popular header and it's it's
used to prevent clickjacking essentially
so you set this header if you want to
prevent other sites from putting your
site in an iframe on that page and I
thought this was the best practice I was
then subsequently I subsequently found
that there is a content security policy
directive called frame ancestors which
allows you to achieve exactly the same
thing but it has two significant
advantages one is the it's fewer headers
because you already have a content
security policy or at least you
certainly should do and the second one
is that the directive as part of CSP is
much better specified than the extra
motion spec so you can count on better
interoperability between browsers so
that was one where I actually changed my
behavior as a result of the research
there was also a blog post that
accompanied your presentation and in it
a lot of the discussion in the comments
had to do with the via header can you
describe the gesture that's conversation
so I think this was a result of some bad
phrasing on my part describing this
particular one because the because wire
is interesting in that it is both a
request and a response header so as a
request header it's actually very
important it performs a very useful
function as requests get
asked from one proxy server up to the
next you know if there's there might be
a number of hops in the chain to get
back to the origin and the via header
ensures that all of those hops in the
chain speak the same version of HTTP and
also to some extent that you don't end
up in a loop where you know say you have
a CDN or another kind of edge network
that uses another CDN as an origin and
that CDN uses the first CDM as an origin
you could end up you know destroying the
internet or something
so the via header to some extent is is
used to prevent those kind of request
loops and it is important that it does
that now the via response header in in
contrast is informational it is added to
as the response comes back through all
of those hops and in the browser you get
to find out all of the proxies that your
response transitive that information is
not particularly useful to an end user
so I felt that it was not necessary to
keep that header and I think those two
concepts the request and the response
got conflated in in people's discussion
of it but I think that was probably
confusion in the way that I phrased it
in the blog post and how did see the end
loop play into them
oh so CDN loop is a concept that we have
been shopping around at fastly and
amongst other CDN vendors and the idea
is that we take that part of via that is
really useful which is to prevent loops
within edge networks and proxies and put
that in a dedicated header which will
avoid some of the baggage that comes
with using via and provide us with a
clean mechanism for preventing these
loop backs between CD ends so this is a
good example of a new HTTP header that
not for many people know about it's not
yet supported by any browsers it also
needs to be supported by the major edge
networks and CD ends and it's a also a
good example of cooperation between
people in the industry so you know
browsers have actually been used to
cooperating and making web standards for
a long time you know I used to sit in a
room with peep
from Google and Microsoft and Apple and
Mozilla and Samsung and you know we
would all talk about web standards and
that exists in that industry in a much
more advanced way than it does in the in
the CDN edge Network industry and I
think CDN loop is a good example of us
starting to push that standards
collaboration forward
you had mentioned CSP earlier do you
have a sense of the success of the
adoption of privacy and security headers
like that so content security policy yes
it's disappointing it's like two and a
half percent it's it depending on how
you look at it it's somewhere between 2%
and 10% but it's it's too low
considering how important CSP is to
preventing cross-site scripting attacks
which is still one of the most common
ways for people to to attack
vulnerabilities on websites people just
are not using this defense mechanism
enough and I think one of the problems
with it is that it is reasonably complex
to implement CSP you know the average
length of CSP that I found in HTTP
archive was 600 bytes it's one of the
longer headers you know I used to think
that we were committing terrible crimes
by having so many cookies on the sites
that I used to work on in in my previous
jobs and then I realized you know that
if you serve a content security policy
head of this this big then that becomes
your biggest the biggest problematic
header but now that we have header
compression it's not so bad well that
does help and we also might come on to
things like origin policy which help as
well but nevertheless the just writing
those 600 bytes is an overhead and I
also found in the archive signs that
people are trying to generate these
headers automatically because I found
one that was over 10k in size which was
listing you know hundreds and hundreds
of advertising third parties that might
be loaded onto the page and you know it
was probably unnecessary it was probably
something that could have been manually
optimized but I suspect what happens is
it's generated source massively in there
no one looks at it so you know you get
that kind of effect and that is really
terrible
because that header it needs to be
loaded prior to the
in the first byte of HTML so you know
that is that is it's stuffing up your
critical path and it's a wait list it
should be us as small as possible so
that you're only allowing a certain
number of well exactly yes so so CSP is
is problematic it's even the two and a
half percent of websites that implement
it often do it in a way that offers them
little to no protection and yet it
remains a very powerful tool if used
well other headers like HSTs that's a
HTTP strict Transport Security is much
more widely used this is ahead of the
forces browsers to connect to your
website over tls/ssl HTTPS so even if
somebody typed in the address of your
website with no HTTP colon slash slash
which is obviously you know everyone the
browser will even then make that very
first connection to your site over TLS
so you won't you won't need to suffer
the latency of a redirect and also you
won't expose your site to that tiny
window of opportunity for an attacker to
it's a man-in-the-middle of connection
so HSTs is a really simple thing
everyone should be using it and it's
very simple to implement the only value
that you give it is a max age so
incredibly simple to apply and IC adapt
turns around 20% which is yeah exactly
so you know as you as you would expect
it's much easier implement so a lot of
people are using it
how about prefer policy yeah so referral
policy is interesting because you know
where you've got CSP has very low
adoption but it's hard to implement HSTs
much higher adoption easy to implement
refer policy is also very important
thing to consider and yet it's very low
adoption about two percent and it's
extremely easy to implement so that was
something that surprised me and I think
the the reason for that might be that
whilst things like cookies are foremost
in the minds of all of us when we're
building websites because we have a lot
of legal obligations and compliance that
we need to deal with that sort of aspect
of security and privacy is distracting
us perhaps from the data leakage that we
might be suffering
by not setting a referral policy and
just to be clear referral policy is a is
a policy that prevents browsers from
sharing the full URL of the page that
the user is on when they click off your
site to go to an external domain so if I
click a link on your site - I don't know
- a Wikipedia page that you've linked to
then Wikipedia will see the full URL of
the page I was on before I ended up on
Wikipedia now maybe that contains some
personal data in the URL
maybe you've included my name on my
email address in a query parameter in
the URL and that's the kind of thing
that the referrer policy will help to
prevent gotcha
so what else did you find related to
performance headers so that the stuff
we've talked about so far I guess is
mostly security and privacy related so
the headers have also been brought to
bear on on performance a lot I think the
most important one that we use today is
link rel preload so link is is an
interesting header because it's
incredibly generic like you know the
origins of link are in the Semantic Web
the idea that you would you would as
metadata for web page you could attach
links to the previous and next chapter
of the book or whatever it is that this
web page is you could you could have a
link to an index or contents now we
don't really use the web like that
anymore
some would say that's a shame but I
think the header averts offers us just
this ability to generically link to
another document and say this is related
in some way it's quite useful for saying
these are resources that are going to be
needed to render this web page so please
load the Mullaly as possible and so that
is what support this link rel equals
preload which particularly is used for
fonts because fonts tend to be
discovered quite late in the process of
passing a web page so by shipping a link
rel preload header for all the fonts
that you're going to use you can
dramatically reduce the chance of a
so-called flash upon the style text so
that will so that that gives you a huge
benefit it's some would say not as good
as it could be and so this is actually
something we've been working on to
create a new spec for something called
early hints so the idea of early hints
is that instead of waiting until the
server is able to determine that the
response is going to be a 200 it's a
sent headers we can send the headers
even earlier so we receive the request
before we even start thinking about
whether this is even a valid request or
not we immediately omit some headers
that say you know what it doesn't really
matter whether this turns out to be a
404 you're probably going to need this
font so please just start loading it
anyway and then if it does turn out
you've you've given us a garbage URL and
this is a 404 page then well our 404
page is probably branded anyway so we're
probably still going to write it in that
font so it makes sense for a small
number of really critical resources to
be loaded even when we haven't
determined the basic status of the
response yet so early hints is very
early stages it requires implementation
not just in browsers but also in web
servers and also in edge networks and CD
ends so this is a very hard one to ship
but we are excited about it because if
we manage to optimize that period of
time when you know we're waiting for the
server to think of a response that is
time that is currently really critical
because the end user is sitting there
waiting for one response and nothing
else is happening on the network so that
is time we could really make use of
looking ahead
are there any headers that aren't
necessarily available in the wild yet
but you're excited about absolutely so
we spent quite a lot of the time on the
tag looking at things like feature
policy feature policy I'm incredibly
psyched about it will enable us for the
first time to start to reduce the size
of the web platform which is interesting
because you know all these standards
they get shipped all the cyma constantly
increasing the size of platform adding
new api is adding new elements adding
new headers and it's become this fairly
unwieldy beast and also if you go back
and you look at sites that haven't been
maintained for a number of years they
might now have security vulnerabilities
that they didn't have
because there are whole API is that have
shipped that didn't exist when that site
was made so feature policy is a way for
you to list features of the web platform
and restrict them to certain origins so
rather like content security policy
restricts access to network destinations
from the page feature policy restricts
access to API is within the page so I
can say for example that video autoplay
is turned off and that means that even
if I write code in my page that attempts
to also play a video it just won't work
because I turned it off in my future
policy now this is really exciting it
means that not only can we we can we
apply some really simple policies to all
of the things that would otherwise
trigger user permission prompts so
things like notifications you know
everyone's starting to be familiar with
all these pages that you know on page
low will immediately say can we send you
notifications
it's a terrible anti-pattern obviously I
have no idea whether I want
notifications from a site that I've only
just opened in my browser sites can
start to say we are a good actor we we
are not going to do that by declaring a
feature policy and just turning off
features of the web that have generally
been agreed upon as bad practices and
and also we can prevent third parties on
the page or maybe our own development
teams from accidentally using things
that we feel we shouldn't use in the
future I'm hoping that feature policy
will get expanded to include all the
kind of patterns that have have been
maintained since sort of the antiquity
of the web things like document write or
synchronous xhr we still work and they
still need to work because you know the
web has this philosophy that that
Geocities slightly you wrote in 1997
should still work but if you write a
site today you're not going to use those
same techniques and it's reasonable to
say let's just turn them off because if
we turn them off browsers can optimize
things better search engines can give
you potentially ranking bonuses for
having good practices on your site and
you can rest more assuredly in the
knowledge that you have a
smaller attack surface for vulnerability
so I am really excited about future
policy and you know and also things like
CDN loop that we talked about earlier
I'd imagine that if you have that data
in the HTTP archive you could see the
features that people disabled and that
would also in aggregate be really
interesting to analyze yeah absolutely
and I think people will be doing that
and an understanding you know how
successful feature policy is it's
enabling that uplift in standards across
the web
so if developers want to learn more
where could they go well you talked
earlier about the the talk that I did
and I turn that talking to a couple of
blog posts one is about best practices
one is about anti-patterns they're both
on the FASTA blog so it's although great
Andrew thank you so much for being here
you're welcome if you'd like to find the
links to all these resources we have
them in the description thank you for
watching we'll see you next time
[Music]